all right Kevin Kevin Oh where'd you
grow up where you from originally grew
up in South Los Angeles area and the
neighborhood of Crips mainly Crips were
Union gangsters again I started
gangbanging around the age of 12 well
then tell you about your family you grew
up with both your parents yes I have
both my parents in my life I'm the
middle child how was your childhood
actually uh my childhood actually on my
grew up in a a well took the care of
family actually uh like I said I'm a
middle child got older brother and
younger sister you know as a little
child you know y'all I feel neglected
which is probably not true I just felt
that way you know took me towards uh
other routes yeah exactly gangs um you
know bad behavior should I say I have
done no prison time in another County
Jail no prison time yeah hopefully I
don't I'm not trying to do that hold it
I'm 30 you're 30 I just turned 30 yeah
kids in Europe no kiss okay no kids so
tell me what your life after you joined
the game
um actually uh let's take this thing
take it back right before then I
actually uh was on the right path you
know the grace I made down the road you
know one of the top students in my class
and until you you know well you hang
with is who you are that's the model and
that's actually true and you know I hung
with certain kids in the neighborhood
and I got used to that used to that
lifestyle and it took me to get up to
take a bullet to uh understand that life
is real so you got shot ass with it at
the age of fourteen yes shot twice in
the leg twice in my own left leg that's
one time you know I got other times I
was here also and I was sixteen I was
also hit in the back end and a leg scars
this is when I was fourteen notice the
first time I received a couple of they
do call this the tibia and it shattered
the bone actually you know the bone
exposed to the air which caused me to
have what they call osteoma losses which
is a bone infection and osteo means boma
lots of the infection and during the
time of my bone infection um I was
prescribed Norco and first time I ever
took that narco one that first that
first Norco that first pills I told
myself wow I love this [ __ ] and I'm
addicted
I swear to God - first time I felt that
when they kicked in I felt that hi I
said this is a high like no other and
every since then man I've been chasing
that high and um you know it it
progresses from Larco to actually
started liking it - Marco from Northcote
it's a purpose that purpose says to
oxycodone without the tylenol inside the
problem oxycodone she's a straight dope
and um what got me really on it was the
street value of oxycodone 30 milligrams
and South Los Angeles street value is
from 15 to $15 to $20 appeal and that's
uh if you sink a lot of pills and
wholesale price you $10 $12 anyway I was
able to get my hands to get that pill
for a dollar so it's very affordable for
me so every day I will pop to 30
milligram oxycontin and it got to the
point when I wake up in the morning I
pop 10 out of time and I was just to get
me started through the day you know you
know around 12 o'clock make you know
[ __ ] I'm getting are getting off the
[ __ ] I'm taking a
another eight what time is nighttime
when I'm getting ready to you know close
close up close a day another eight nine
maybe ten throughout the whole day man I
just popped about fifty goddamn pills
yeah and you're very affordable for me
because like I told you I was getting
for a dollar
Street values for fifteen to twenty
dollars so you can imagine me able to
get my hands on that peel for $1 you go
crazy go nuts so once I lost that on
that value that dollar value I start
experiencing withdrawals and being sick
dope sick I never thought that I never
thought our experience I never thought
I'd get to that point I never thought
that it happened it happens you know
rather [ __ ] be dead and he'd rather
be dead than feel that feeling that dope
feeling that so I felt that that that
dope sick I knew with opiates and I knew
that here on is an opiate and I knew
that is is actually also affordable so
on by me knowing knowing that I know
about skid row downtown Los Angeles I
decided to take a take a trip down here
and the first person I encountered man
hacks where's you know where the dope
where the hell Ron first was I
encountered he had I took that dope went
home I'm by myself you know with nobody
nobody got me on this I went to the
house
believe it or not I you know we got
these Android phones I went to youtube
and I'm trying to see how the hell I'm
gonna do this drug you know I got it
hiding the [ __ ] I'll get high off for
this [ __ ] so first thing I read was
chased the dragon chased the dragon is
me put it on the foil make a little what
they call it a tutor it's like a straw
and you put a flame under that for you
right right on top is uh you know the
hair Ron and it burns in milks and as a
denotes a cloud of smoke coming you
chasing with the straw I didn't do quite
a good job on that one I didn't get high
I was wasting the dope I figured I would
do that so I bought more dope when I
bought the dope I bought quite a I've
spent about $100 on because I knew that
I'll be [ __ ] up I know I'll be
[ __ ] up I'm trying to do it so check
the drug just wasn't me he leave me put
that to the side second what they said
take a body's eaten bottle empty of the
advising bottle rinse it out and you put
your little you put your dope inside put
some water shake it up let him milk and
now you got it to where you can snort it
and like that I fix me he fixed me I no
longer was dope sick but I didn't like
get high
and trying my heart to stay away from
that needle man but I didn't like those
two options and I got a grandmother who
was a diabetic man already had needles
in the house it was already in the house
so I got on YouTube how the hell do I
bang this house language they tell me I
can use a spoon or just metal top there
which they call a cooker tell me how
much water to use told me to put a
cotton to filter out you can use a
cigarette time from a cigarette butt or
a q-tip some kind of cotton they filter
out that dope - it's a so you won't you
know draw up the cut or you know all the
bad particles that come along with the
dope he's trying to get as much as a
purity purity out of them and you're
good that's why cotton is for so uh
anyway come on YouTube step by step just
figure out how can I fix lamb this I was
successful got it all into the tool I
got my syringe out that I got about
sixty units or 60 cc's a dope decided a
syringe now I'm trying to find a vein
here it is I'm in and out the hospital
before this like I told her I didn't
being shot I didn't had bone infections
and all kind of [ __ ] happening was oh I
pretty much kind of know how to get that
vein and watching the nurses and the
doctors give me bound that first try man
that [ __ ] shot that blood shot shot up
in the shot right up in that syringe
being in here I go she's pushed II ten
seconds
five seconds ten seconds I gotta rush so
rush man like no other I swear to God
that rush was twenty hundred times way
more way more powerful and way more
better then that first normal I told you
I totally [ __ ] [ __ ] I knew I knew it
was old I [ __ ] up I know I wouldn't
going back to pills that first time I
banged it I knew I was not gonna take
another pill again but I talked to
myself I took so many pills I thought I
[ __ ] up my kidneys
sorry probably I almost thought I was
doing myself a favor
that's what my life really many expired
down here
I'm chasing that high
trucks are so loud I'm sorry since idiot
yeah like I was saying on this one my
life really spiraled downhill when I
really started chasing this high and uh
got affordable drug no longer became
affordable now you start stealing from
your mama's purse start stealing from
your loved ones just for a high this
when it becomes a problem just need to
know you got a problem you know I got a
problem so how many years has it been
that even using heroin
I'm 30 years old started heading on when
I was about 26 is about the fourth year
maybe even 25 probably about five years
for five years on hair rock and popping
opiates taking opiates since I was about
17 it's no [ __ ]
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say sixteen
that's when I was really really popular
but uh playing with the 14th and with
like 14 but what addicted wasn't a
problem became problems about 50 16 17
so that's when became a problem and I
was popping those pills every goddamn
day too I was about 25 I counted that
hair run that's when life really began
for us so what it was what does your
hair heroin addiction cost you though
they're on addiction cost me down in my
life few times I I got heart failure
I got chronic kidney failure from the
abscess that's from that's how dirty
this drug is so that's from an abscess
it's from an abscess that says coitus is
from dirty Oh it comes from a lot of
things it can come from dirty needles in
my case mines come from the dope it's
not clean yeah one thing I didn't cut
with something here there's a cut
something in that dope that my body just
don't accept how long you have this
would um [ __ ] man this started towards
somewhere in the beginning stages of me
taking here Ronnie I've been having this
ever since you had this for a few years
I've been having this for a while
on and off it never ever completely
healed I'll tell you yet never ever
completely healed and actually to tell
you the truth man is just looking better
than it actually ever did look really as
you can tell when this thing was here to
here so I'm about more than half her
size everybody used to he's starting to
close finally but if I don't stop doing
what I'm doing man I'm gonna lose his
arm
I've been threatened and you read
multiple times you're living on Skid Row
by choice don't have to entertain
[Music]
sometimes I do have a duality yes it's a
filthy lifestyle that it's nothing that
you never want to do but because it's
gotten for having his drug you would do
anything to stay close by - like I said
dope stick is something that you try to
prevent and um in order for you not to
be dope sick man you gotta be hard you
got to be you got out of that drill
again you know that's what caused me to
stay on Skid Row as you said earlier
you'd rather die than in desync than
bead up sir yes sir
the idea of how difficult it is to get
off the drug Bob still owning in fact
that I just I shot before this video and
I might shoot the Aptus how many - how
many times a day to you thanks
I'm shooting about two to three grams a
day what are you doing for money
anything cut hair
it's stealing so it's Robbie
anything I wear I go say any times these
things are yeah you know Hey
you just just just want more did you
just won't do you know nothing uh I'm
not gonna go there
you guys know what I'm talking about I
won't go there
but yeah I do go farther know you had
medical attention for this of course
absolutely actually uh you just came to
the hospitals came from the hospital
they didn't wrap it up bandage it I took
it off why would you dope Oh cuz you
[ __ ] right into that
something that y'all don't want to do
may take this take this for even they
think that they think they're saying it
you're saying it I never thought I'd be
here I never thought that I never
thought that I couldn't be doing this
you know I come from a family loving
caring family I'm hurting them you know
I'm hurt no they uh they love me dearly
I haven't even let me go yet they know
you're in the situation they know I'm in
a situation they're trying to help but
it's up to me don't get why one Hill I
do won't help
I do want to stop but this demon man
it's a demon and it's uh it's by far one
of the hardest thing I ever encountered
the hardest battle I never ever ever
fought that I'm still fighting right now
it's winning it's one that's getting the
best time but I pray that uh one day I
will thank you so much
thank you
you